president Trump leading the way on
police reform while defending cops and
promising to restore law and order
Trump signing an executive order after
weeks of protests it bans chokeholds
unless an officer's life is in danger
it also calls for more police training
and creates a database to track cops
with complaints against them here's the
president earlier these standards will
be as high and as strong as there is on
earth the vast majority of police
officers are selfless and courageous
public servants choke halls will be
banned except if an officer's life is at
risk we will have reform without
undermining our many great and extremely
talented law enforcement officers Trump
slamming the far left goal to defund
police warning that getting rid of cops
would be catastrophic I strongly oppose
the radical and dangerous efforts to
defend dismantle and dissolve our police
departments especially now when we've
achieved the lowest recorded crime rates
in recent history Americans know the
truth without police there is chaos
without law there is anarchy and without
safety there is catastrophe alright so
Dana the left's never going to be
satisfied with what the president
proposals on this but if there's going
to be reform you got to get the Senate
involved you got to get the house
involved so where do we go from here
well I think I think that there is a
chance that you could get something done
but it's a small chance and so I think
that's why the president took the
opportunity to do an executive order now
we all know that executive orders are
not as strong as legislation so you have
senator Tim Scott
appointed by Mitch McConnell to lead
this effort for the Republicans in the
Senate what I thought was pretty
disappointing jesse is that brian schatz
of hawaii was basically suggesting that
tim scott is not good enough on this
issue like he basically was suggesting
he wasn't the best person to deal with
it like tim scott wasn't just plucked
out
obscurity to start working on this he's
actually been working on these pieces of
legislation for a long time and because
timing is everything in politics this is
the perfect time so I think it's pretty
unfortunate that some Senate Democrats
are already dismissing an issue from a
black Republican senator of which they
always point out he's the one black
Republican senator well the Democrats
have two and up in minute Michigan John
James is the Republican Senate candidate
and Jerry Peter let me Gary Peters who
is the incumbent running against him the
white Democrats of all the Democrats are
helping support a white candidate versus
a black candidate in Michigan so that
kind of political stuff is going to
happen between now and then but this
small chance that the presidency is in
order to get some legislation done it
would be possible if you listen to Nancy
Pelosi she sounds like she's willing to
do something and sign a deal the problem
will be will the far-left allow that to
happen I think the president could
convene a meeting and try to get
everybody in the same room and put the
speaker on the spot to see if she's
willing to come to the table and help
out reach a hand across the aisle or I
guess elbow bump now whatever that is
that we have to do because that would be
a way to try to get something done that
would be stronger than the executive
order yeah that's interesting I guess
there's a lot more pressure from the
Left Dagan on this issue and you know
man she's probably not going to get a
hundred percent not eighty percent but
maybe she gets 30 to 40 percent is that
going to be good enough politically in
an election year it's hard to believe
that the Democrats would give President
Trump any sort of win in an election
year despite the fact that it would help
all Americans because right now
President Trump was standing up there
trying to reassure black Americans that
things will change in policing things
will change in this country and at the
same time reassure all Americans that
they will still be safe and protected
at the same time reach out to police
departments to ensure that the entire
nation is on the same page heading in
the same direction but with many
Democrats as we always see we're goal is
of what the president says they have one
or they have two things that they will
go to they will scream too much over
each dictator or too little too wimpy
weakling and then follow that up with
Russia Russia Russia and I think a lot
of Democrats are falling again and into
the camp of he's not doing enough and
this is these are some things that were
proposed by President Obama five years
ago yeah one what do you think about the
chokehold situation this or those are
proposed to be banned but they carve out
an exemption if you know it's life and
death struggle the guys reaching for
your gun you're trying to gain leverage
I know you're an athletic guy you
understand what it's like to be
grappling with people how do you see
that chokehold deal well I think you
know the first thing is to reiterate
something we heard earlier I think Dana
said it you know choke an executive
order is not a law and executive orders
are easily overturned Jesse and in this
case you have an executive order that
really what it says is the officer if
the officer decides he wants to use a
chokehold he can use it and then later
say he felt his life was at risk so to
me this rings very hollow I just think
that if the president was serious about
this he'd be working with Tim Scott he'd
be working with Nancy Pelosi to get
something into law something that was
hard and fast what we have not seen
though is that the Republicans and here
I think Tim Scott is working hard at it
but he can't get Mitch McConnell to
agree to act on it now McConnell wants
to push it until after the 4th of July
holiday Tim Scott wants to do something
now I think everybody in the country
wants to do something right now so I
think the best thing would be for the
president to say to Mitch McConnell
let's get this done senator let's make
this happen
important for America the second thing I
would say is you know I would love him
to give a speech Jesse about these
unions especially since I think too
often they're protecting bad cops and
it's really at the root of the problem I
mean up in New York you guys had a
situation just yesterday where you had
the police union tweeting out about
workers at Shake Shack are poisoning
cops and then it turns out no no such
thing happens according to the New York
Police Department but they want to
demonize everybody but the police this
is this is hurting their own cause and I
just think it's time for us to get
something done and we can use a
president who would really speak
directly to the problem all right Greg I
feel like you might disagree with that
just a little bit I'll give you the last
word well so what is it we have to
define what the problem is okay so
there's 50 million police encounters a
year out of that there are 50 deaths of
unarmed people some are black more or
white that's an error rate of 1 per
million ok that's a error rate of point
zero zero zero one percent that's that's
three times lower than what we accept in
machine processing so it's a
one-in-a-million chance and we are
trying to bring that one-in-a-million
chance to zero in a million chance that
is possible with reform to bring it from
one in a million to zero in a million
but just by chance and error
incompetence resistance a bad cop it
goes right back up to one in a million
so it's gonna be a very difficult thing
because it's a rare mistake
that costs lives one in a million and
the variables that are three combination
of three there are bad laws like no
knock there are resisting arrest which
once once that starts something off it
never goes back to being good and bad
training and tactics you combine those
you get one in a million tragedies so I
have a solution to end this Society
upheaval and it will eradicate all
perceptions and I mean perceptions of
racism in policing not the realities but
the
perception it's a great idea but it's
also a terrible idea
but I don't care because I will take the
terrible idea over a disintegration of
our society in our country so here's the
terrible idea
I call it officer recusal when there is
a black suspect all white officers
recuse themselves and they call in the
nearest black officer who responds and
handles the case
likewise when there is a white suspect
black officers recused and a white
officer is called in and that is not
about race that is because the black
officer will be likely in demand for
other issues going on in other
communities all right what does that do
this is a discriminatorily
discriminating idea but it removes race
from the equation leaving only tactics
and training you could only look at
tactics and training with a white cop
and a white suspect a black cop and a
black suspect the downside for all of
this is that the black officers will be
working in communities where there'll be
higher crime rates and there will be a
higher demand for black officers which
means maybe they should be paid more
that's also discriminating correct and
that's racist but I have to say this I
will take discrimination when black cops
are paid more in certain communities if
it saves our society and gets rid of
this racial narrative it's the only
solution for this it's a bad solution
but you can't let the perfect be the
enemy of the good which i think is the
phrase I coined just now